we're going to begin with some breaking
news from Thailand at least 31 people
including children have been killed in a
shooting in the northeast of the country
the Thai government has said that it
happened at a daycare center in Nong wa
lampu and I believe police have now
launched a Manhunt let's go straight to
Tony Chang who is in Bangkok for us this
sounds like incredibly tragic
incident talk us through exactly what
you know
we understand that the Emergency
Services were first alerted at 12 30
local time that's about two and a half
hours ago with a report of a disturbance
at this daycare center in uh noncar and
non-ual and puts a province in the
northeast of Thailand we understand that
now there are more than 31 fatalities
including a large number of children a
suspect was chased from the scene in a
white pickup truck the the time media is
saying that he's a former Thai policeman
who was relieved of his duty earlier
today but at this stage very little more
is is known about this the casualty
figures do seem to be rising very
quickly though so unfortunately it
appears this was a very tragic uh
incident and again involving a large
number of children okay Tony thank you
for that update as soon as we have any
more developments on the story we will
of course bring it to you Tony Chang
there in Bangkok on that tragic incident
31 people that we know of have been
killed so far in a shooting at a daycare
center in non-wa lampu